one of the things we've learned to pay
special attention to over the last few
years is when the american republican
party says
this is what the left is going to do
we should look really carefully at
whether what they mean is we're actually
already doing this and when it comes to
voter fraud we've increasingly learned
that all of the fear-mongering and all
of the allegations about what democrats
and the left are going to do
was actually stuff that almost
exclusively it was republicans doing
people voting twice people voting in the
names of dead people all of these
different things
we see
endless instances on the right and
donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows is now really caught in the
crosshairs i recently told you guys that
meadows is under investigation for was
he registered to vote where he actually
lived there's some really fishy stuff
going on and the latest news is that
mark meadows has indeed now been removed
from the north carolina voter rolls in
the middle of this investigation axios
reporting former white house chief of
staff mark meadows was removed from
north carolina's voter roll monday
why it matters the move comes amid an
investigation into meadows for alleged
voter fraud related to his voter
registration the probe followed reports
which revealed that meadows registered
to vote in north carolina in september
2020 using an address he allegedly never
visited
state of play meadows was removed from
the north carolina voter roll after
documentation indicated uh-oh he lived
in virginia and last voted in the 2021
election there
no formal challenge has been received by
the macon county board of elections
the last election he voted in making
county was 2020.
under state law if a north carolina
voter exercises the right of a citizen
by voting in an election in another
state the person is considered to have
lost their north carolina residents now
there's two issues here remember
republicans kept talking about people
registered to vote in two places that's
not against the law as long as you don't
vote in two places it's very common
that somebody lives in one place and you
register and then you move somewhere
else and you register there you're not
automatically removed from the
registration at the old place you're
registered in two places i believe
tiffany trump trump's daughter had this
going on
as long as you don't vote twice it's
okay you haven't actually done anything
wrong
the next part with the mark meadows
investigation is
the register the address where he was
supposedly registered to vote or where
he was registered to vote where he
supposedly lived
was not a place he had our allegedly
even been to it if i recall correctly it
was a trailer of some kind and the
circumstances are all extraordinarily
bizarre now it shouldn't come like as a
complete and total shock to us
that this is really common but also
remember that donald trump multiple
times talked about you should try voting
twice this all of this vote by mail
thing it's so complicated that maybe you
should try voting twice here's just one
time that donald trump said this mark
meadows was trump's chief of staff at
this time
sign your melon ballot okay you sign it
right and send it in and then you have
to follow it
and if on election day or
early voting
that is not
tabulated and counted you go vote
and then if for some reason after that
it shouldn't take that long it comes in
they're not going to be able to tabulate
it because you will have voted but you
have to make sure your vote counts
because the only way they're going to
beat us
is by doing that kind of stuff so trump
said even if you submit a mail-in vote
you should still go and try to vote
again because if they don't receive
anyway but what he's saying is try to
vote twice
try to vote twice and of course it all
is predicated on the idea that the
mail-in votes are going to just end up
some some kind of netherworld some kind
of election purgatory of sorts uh but
remember
they never actually cared about voter
fraud they they never really cared about
it they care about
what are the ways
in which they can weaponize confusion
and misinformation to help themselves
win
they want to use voter fraud as an issue
to make it harder to vote and that
includes closing polling places reducing
early voting hours reducing vote by mail
doing doing all of the things that make
it harder to vote strategically only in
certain places notice that they don't
really care about this in california
they don't care about this in
massachusetts
they don't care about this in
connecticut they care about it in places
where they can think to themselves okay
let's evaluate the electorate
and evaluate policy and if it's a state
that could be close
let's see what kind of
disinformation we can push or what kind
of laws we could seek to have changed
that would maybe give us a little bit of
an edge or at least give us the
opportunity to later challenge it that's
another part of it because sometimes we
hear oh well it it's not clear that
closing polling places in michigan
would help them in the sense that you
might close polling places in michigan
and it makes it harder for democrats and
republicans to vote okay maybe
first of all typically they argue for
polling places to be closed in urban
areas that have more democratic voters
they'll say
there's too many polling place we don't
need this many polling places so that
makes it harder for democratic-leaning
areas to vote but the other part of it
is
they just want to create a pretext to
then later challenge votes
and uh making changes to where and when
and how you can vote creates a pretext
that then you can use to say things
didn't go right we're filing a lawsuit
or we're filing a complaint of some kind
um what else did we have i mean this
these are really the main things and uh
as as always if they keep saying the
left is going to do this it probably
means they're already doing it
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account
you can create multiple cards delete
them freeze them set a spending limit on
them let's say i'm signing up for a free
trial and it requires a credit card
privacy will autofill a virtual card
number and then after signing up i can
delete that virtual card so i know i'm
not going to be charged again something
really useful and very practical or
let's say i'm ordering food over the
phone but i left my wallet somewhere i
don't have my real credit card on me i
can use a virtual card on my privacy
mobile app but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video